a cast of CW's Riverdale also hit up
comic-con it's their first without their
beloved co-stars with Perry yes and we
did find out they will pay tribute to
him for the show's season four premiere
with help from his former TV love and
longtime friend shannen doherty
what was it like bringing her into the
mix knowing that she was someone who had
such a special connection with Lou
it was incredibly special to know that
she was such a big part of his life and
I think it just makes his tribute
episode that much more special mm-hmm
details about the role Shannon will be
playing are being kept secret but the
star who was just spotted returning to
Vancouver where she shoots 902 1o posted
this pic saying the care in which this
show takes in honoring his memory is
beautiful he is miss Today Tomorrow
forever at Riverdale's Comic Con panel
executive producer Roberto
aguirre-sacasa told the audience how her
appearance came to be one of the things
that we had talked about since season
one is he really wanted his good friend
Authority
[Applause]
the show also honored booth by sharing
some never-before-seen bloopers from
season 3
that's Archie he's graceful but it's not
all laughs for the Riverdale cast new
reports today say Cole Sprouse and Lily
Reinhardt have broken up after two years
of dating a source tells us the pair
avoided each other at the Entertainment
Weekly party on Saturday night also at
the bash KJ app' and actress Britt
Robertson and eye witness spotted them
kissing and holding hands the two
previously starred together in 2017 a
dog's purpose
[Music]
[Applause]